[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here today I have
Anna who is a jujitsu blue belt under
Bruno Barbosa so the reason why I got it
in today it's because I want you to
teach the audience really simple
self-defense moves just in case they get
into situations where they need to
protect themselves so what can we expect
from you today so we're gonna look at
very simple moves that do not require
strength because sometimes the victim
cannot overpower the aggressor correct
because they might be larger and a lot
stronger physically so we're gonna look
at very efficient moves that you can
employ and you can learn very easily
okay so pretty much they are really
simple moves things that everybody can
learn yes correct and so what's gonna
happen is I'm going to be the aggressor
and Anna you're going to be the victim
yes okay so I know I'm gonna be in a lot
of pain right let's get straight into
the five moves every woman should know
[Music]
so the first move we're gonna look at is
if we're walking on the street and
somebody just grabs our heart right so
say I grab you're here yes so what
you're gonna do is you're going to put
your hands over the person's fingers
over the knuckles and you're going to
swing your arm to grab their wrist
and once you're in this position you
will push down so they aggressive [ __ ]
fall down yeah or the aggressor will
fall down because of the pressure so if
you try and stand up you can't run and
then you can disengage and you can bang
on okay yeah so the goal is not to show
up but to protect yourself and them so
the goal is essentially to disengage
from the person and to remove yourself
in the situation it's not to stand fire
right and why would someone usually like
say grab someone so essentially when
they grab you they want to control you
so you're not gonna give the control to
them you have to remember that if your
victim in this situation you have to
control what happens next so if he wants
your arm yeah instead of pushing away
yeah so instead of pulling it away you
hold him down towards your wrist so you
take control back from the situation and
then you swing it and you hold the wrist
and then you push it downwards all right
so the second move is if you're out and
somebody just comes up to you puts the
arm around you okay so let's say hey
what's up girl yeah exactly
so again this has happened he's come
into your space and he's trying to take
control of your body you can see his
hips are against your hips and stuff
trying to control you so instead of
pushing away take control as well
exactly so instead of pushing him away
and trying to run so you grab the wrist
you hold it down and you just hold the
person shoulder here then you turn back
and you swing the arm behind and from
this position you would push down on the
knee and then you disengage okay right
shall we just do that once more for the
audience to really see so
all right so you would grab the wrist to
control and then you would grab to both
arms you can 20 hold on you're
controlling both arm so essentially if
you want it to run now let's say I
really want to like push you away yeah
I've taken control of the situation
all right then I'd swing back and I'd
hold your arm against your back okay
against my back here yep and then I
would kick behind your knee to make you
fall and then I disengage and I'd run
off all right right let's do it fast
okay ready hey girl
okay and though you would run away and
then I would run away yes if somebody
comes and grabs your hair yeah like
really aggressive really hard right and
it's hard in this situation because your
first response is to try and sleep yeah
or to grab someone's hair back but you
can't really run when somebody pulls you
back this way mm-hm
so you'd swing your arm over essentially
make them fall okay so if someone grabs
your hair instead of grabbing their hair
bag yeah so then all right so you swing
your arm and you see how I thought of
like definitely no position right now
I let the wrist go yeah just below yeah
I'm in the elbow and when I push up okay
and the president should fall and in
this situation I can punch your face and
then I can run off right
so if ever you get into a catfight you
know what to do yeah this is to protect
yourself not to be aggressive this
happens a lot when you're walking on
your own and somebody just comes up to
you and you just grab you from behind
right and a lot of women will panic here
because they've controlled they would do
that you know someone's control your
shoulders yeah and he has you know the
person has control of you essentially
right so right this is what you should
do
okay someone comes up to you all right
the first thing you're gonna do is
you're gonna make sure that you don't
want to get choked so you're going to
grab the wrist okay and you're gonna
drop down so you're heavy now yeah yep
and you always have to make sure your
face is turn to the side why because if
I was still facing forward as a children
there okay so protect yourself first
even if I have my wrist my hands here if
he's really strong that will go so I
have to secure that Scott and be heavy
turn my neck and then go behind you all
right then I would grab behind your
knees
okay all right and you see how my center
of gravity is low and I'm already kind
of listing you yep and you pick them up
and if you do it this fast it's gonna
really injured someone yeah person's
gonna penny if you're on the street it's
gonna hurt yeah because they're gonna
drop onto concrete yeah and you don't
need strength because you're using you
don't because I'm low and I'm using my
center of gravity to lift you up okay
and so what happens from here so from
here if we were talking from jiu-jitsu
point of view I am to go to side control
and then I'd go to knee on belly okay
and I disengage and run away sometimes
you're unlucky and the fight comes to
the ground because he's a lot stronger
and he's managed to take control of you
and now he was trying to choke you okay
so I would control both the elbows and
push down yep then I would put my legs
up over your shoulders right and I would
bring my hips okay essentially what has
just happened to the aggressor so what
happens to the aggressor is that your
elbows are being controlled and pushed
inwards
yeah and then I'm using this like a
pivot okay so you're breaking so
essentially I'm breaking the elbows yeah
okay so let's do that for the audience
to see once more let's break it down
here so let's say if you end up in this
situation the aggressor is trying to
talk to you yes so the first thing I
want to do is before you even put your
arms around your hands around my neck I
want to secure you again I don't want
you to run away so I would close my legs
into a closed guard that's what we call
it in jujitsu all right
then with your hands on my neck I would
control both your elbows so bring the
elbows close together yes okay so bring
the elbows inwards and I'd push down all
right and I throw my legs over your
shoulders okay and I would lift my hips
up yes
so essentially what you're doing is
closing everything and breaking yes so
I'm keeping control of your elbows and
I'm pinning your wrist down and I'm
lifting it with my hips okay and then
once he is in pain or the aggressor is
in pain yeah and then I would so after
that happens and I'd say I broke in your
arms I would let go I'd kick away and
that I'd get up and run and run yes if
you were to put a little bit more
pressure I would have broken a lot of
bones so these are really simple
effective and efficient moves which FEMA
can basically learn they don't need a
lot of strength correct exactly so we're
not using strength at all in this
situation we're just using leverage with
dropping our center of gravity down and
we're finding efficient moves to
disengage from the situation and to run
away yeah so instead of getting panic
and trying to just push your aggressor
away take control yes so take control of
the situation you've been put into and
come out on top
thank you so much Anna thank you so much
for coming over and teaching us these
really effective moves so don't forget
to follow Anna on Instagram page a lot
more cool jujitsu moves yes so you can
follow me on Shaheen as hollom and we've
also recently started a specific
Instagram page for female athletes
female jujitsu athletes in Malaysia
it's called Malaysian Gigi Tara's and
she follow us there too be sure to check
it out right above here all the links
will be in my description box below
I had fun and I'm in pain